you being kicked out of Nikki Haley's uh
uh event and and also Ron's event too
right yeah so I showed up to Nikki
Haley's event I've been in town since
last Friday and I've been covering all
the different events I was at Trump
rallies and I went to a v ramas swame
event the other day and every candidate
has allowed me inside except Ronda
santis and Nikki Haley and I had tickets
for both of their events and before
Nikki's event could even begin I'm just
standing there her staff let me in they
asked me if I wanted to volunteer and
then all of a sudden I'm surrounded by
two police officers in Iowa and
Indianola and they threatened to arrest
me and trespass me unless I left and
it's like uh hello I have a ticket so
the video went viral it has over 15
million views on X alone vas swame
commented on it because it's like you
want to be president how are you going
to be president Nikki Haley likes to
talk big talk about how oh I have my
ammunition heals and I'm gonna you know
be against the dictators and Trump's a
dictator but isn't that dictator
behavior and if you're scared of Laura
lommer how are you going to sit across
the table from Putin